all right superlatives time what do you
got well okay I mean I think the first
one I want to go to go with is thank you
for your blessing award and it goes to
that game okay cuz I thought we haven't
talked about that yet in the Pope we
know gave the little tweet yesterday
that of course somehow and social media
got mixed up and it became the Saints
fleur-de-lis cache tag same for the for
the fans out there but Pope is
infallible yeah so the Pope meant to do
it doesn't do anything by accident right
he's infallible I am with that and he
knew that the Saints were he was looking
at the line yesterday and he said what
they're underdogs this is crazy but I
gotta give the New Orleans Saints a lot
of credit a lot of credit just the way
they're playing football right now they
find ways to win games week after week
whether it's defense run game Teddy
Bridgewater playing really smart
understanding really the the full scope
of what each game it takes at the
quarterback position and not kind of
like you know overdoing it as far as
trying to make plays or trying to look
cool and sexy on the offensive side of
the ball he's really played well and and
managed games the correct way and I
don't sit here and go like oh gosh if
Drew Brees prayed yesterday they would
have thrown for 400 yards no I I don't
think like in some of these games I
don't think the stats would be a whole
lot different at Drew Brees was playing
but their defense is phenomenal I got to
give Dennis Allen a lot of credit early
in the year you've heard me say this
they were playing a lot of man-to-man
I'm letting up some big plays they have
switched their formula on the back end
their defensive line is as good as it
gets their offensive lines as good as it
gets and Teddy Bridgewater is really
doing a nice job and that's why you pay
money to have a backup quarterback when
you think you're a Super Bowl contender
I talked to cam Jordan after the game he
had both sacks of gardner minshew and he
said one of the keys for that defense is
a lot of those guys have been there for
three years sure so the defense isn't
dealing with new pieces new parts and
let me know every check faster right
right you do this I'm gonna do that or
we can switch roles you do that and I'll
do this and there is something to that
and when you think about cam Jordan's
career with the Saints he arrived in
2011 as a first round pick he's been
around for some
bad defense right the three years post
bounty gate where they were horrendous
they were historically bad they have
found their way with Dennis Allen at
some point he's gonna start being
mentioned as a potential head coaching
candidate might be interesting to see
these teams that have really good
defenses yeah will we go against the
grain of you must be a young offensive
mastermind to be a head coaching
candidate guys like Robert Solow guys
like Dennis Allen will they be in the
mix for jobs next year this Saints
defense has been phenomenal and they got
it done yesterday so yeah the Pope they
can thank the Pope the Pope the Pope
gets the award what will send will be
sending something over to the Vatican
for the Pope okay all right inside
information award yeah is my first when
it goes to Gerald McCoy and the Carolina
Panthers and I spoke to McCoy after they
bedeviled Jameis Winston on Sunday in
London McCoy said look I Jameis Winston
for years with him he likes to step up
in the pocket yeah I spread the word and
we got pressure up the middle they
sacked him seven times he had a bunch of
mistakes it was classic bad Jameis
Winston like bad Jameis Winston has been
lurking all year long
right and Bruce Arians has been doing
the best he can it's like having a dog
then wants to run through the yard and
bite somebody like you keep it under
control and you keep it under control
all it takes is one day though and the
dog gets loose and he starts biting
everybody that's what happened yesterday
with Jameis Winston and on the same day
that Marcus Mariota got benched yeah
Jameis Winston the other top to pick in
the 2015 draft yeah horrible and if I
think if they had somebody really
believed and if Blaine Garrett was
healthy maybe he would have gotten
benched during that game on Sunday that
disaster for the Bucs that sees them
fall to are they two and four now
they're two and four and when you look
at where the Saints are I called it an
NFC South championship elimination game
the loser of that game is gonna have a
hard time catching the Saints right a
very hard time and now you look at the
Bucs at two and four and they've already
lost to the Saints once for them it's
scramble for a wild card in that
division that we've been talking about
all morning or they're in the conference
that is chock-full of great teams that
are already squatting on the five seed
in the six see ya know there was a you
know an ugly showing for that Bucs
offense now I understand Jameis
Winston's yes mistakes certainly big
issue
okay he's I think a much better
quarterback still than Marcus Mariota I
just want to make that clear absolutely
awesome well yeah but Jameis Winston
let's not forget the few weeks before
this he's been phenomenal it was ten
touchdown zero interceptions in every
game since week one it wasn't his fault
damn Bruce Arians screwed up the end of
the game of the the Giants - I'm just
trying to give him a little bit here but
either way yes we saw a little bit of
like that governor that we've seen you
know oh okay let me throw the ball away
or I'll just take the sack you know the
the big the worst one to me is when they
were down in the red zone and he
scrambled out to the right and just like
again lost sight of like hey there's
defensive linemen that are chasing you
this is called football and he moves and
just keeps and you continue to hold the
ball I'll say this also on his defense
two men was he under attack to some of
those interceptions you know he got hit
as he was throwing the ball but either
way it was not a good look and yeah now
you worry about you know does this
continue to be a theme with Jameis
Winston this year and maybe Bruce Arians
can't get it out of this thing about
Jameis Winston Arian said it yesterday
he tries to be Superman yeah and the one
thing that is so relatable about Jameis
Winston I think we've all been there at
some time in our lives when we're doing
something athletic that our brain
believes we are capable of doing it
right but our body isn't capable of
executing the commands and dictated by
our brain right that happens to Winston
and Aryans have been able to keep it
under wraps for most of the year and his
passer rating was phenomenal except for
a weak one and yesterday he had 100 plus
he had a 120 point five rating against
the the Rams just a couple of weeks ago
but 46.8 yesterday against the Carolina
Panthers not good at all five picks
seven sacks and you just have to wonder
what Bruce Arians is thinking about
Jameis Winston at this point ultimately
what the organization is gonna think
yeah no doubt you know they're in a
tough spot but I still think they'll
ride with him and and I still think he
gives them the best chance as far as
anybody on that team is concerned all
right my next one mistakes by the lake
okay and that goes to the Cleveland
Browns Seattle Seahawks football game
which was a lot of fun to watch
yesterday and Cleveland had
opportunities to win this football game
but really this may continue to make big
mistake
and big parts of the game whether it's
you know being stopped on fourth and one
whether it's Jarvis Landry at fourth and
one from the goal line okay whether it's
Jarvis Landry where I do think he scored
but there wasn't a great angle as the
show at he fumbles as he's going into
the end zone
Baker Mayfield throwing a ball behind
the receiver kind of to contestant in
the end zone ball pops in the air
interception Baker Mayfield interception
at the end of the game throwing the ball
behind Hilliard Nick Chubb when they're
on the verge of the red zone once again
you know running out to the left
getting the ball stripped out of his
hands by a Zico Lanza who has the strip
fumble recovery
so there was a lot of issues in that
game I mean hey we know Seattle's gonna
battle and they can cause havoc in a
game and they always create turnovers
and Russell Wilson is the MVP of
football right now but there's a game
where the young team that's still trying
to figure out its way you know they
probably could have won or should have
won that game yesterday but you know
they're learning how to win in the NFL
as we're watching them right now and
yesterday was a game they blew because
of kind of their inconsistencies and
carelessness with the ball up 22:6
and look the deters between a team with
a championship pedigree and a team that
is trying to build one is the team with
the championship pedigree knows how to
turn it around and dig out of that hole
and the team that is up by 14 yeah may
be inclined to think all right here we
go we're gonna get this one it's going
our way and the next thing you know it's
not going your way when I look at this
schedule coming up they have the bye
week and they need it they just need it
Baker Mayfield needs it right he's got a
hip injury he admitted after the game
it's tender it's sore at New England
which is not gonna be an easy no at
Denver the following week which all of a
sudden that'll be tough it's not gonna
be an easy never easy to play Buffalo at
home oh geez oh baby and then the
Steelers well and that's the thing we
were saying how the schedule softens
after week 10 that's not that soft oh
that's a Thursday night game visit from
the Steelers and here's the thing about
the Steelers in primetime yeah in
primetime
yeah they show what they show up they do
they showed up against the Bengals they
showed up against the Chargers and
they're gonna show up against the Browns
because even if the Steelers have no
chance to get into the playoffs this
year and right now they're just they're
just what a game behind the brown their
time at the Browns right they're top at
the browser the two games behind the
Ravens right the Steelers maybe
still jockeying for position these games
are not gonna be easy and the only the
games that are standing out are the two
games against the Bengals Washington
they know I'm looking at the preseason
sorry two games against the Bengals and
Miami yeah those are the only three
games on the back end of the schedule
but I say the Browns who are gonna have
an easy time of it now and you know it
may be that they do not finish with that
same yeah seven eight and one or better
record than they had last no they might
not yeah you're right I mean they're
they got a lot of games to play here and
they got a tough schedule certainly in
it and Russell Wilson's awesome I mean I
mean how awesome is Russell Wilson I
mean he really is we don't heat you know
he just the plays he makes some of the
throws he makes it's phenomenal we take
it for granted yeah we do we take it for
granted you know I just I think after
six weeks I'm gonna go yo Kurt Warner my
my quarterback ratings for better than
yours because Tom Brady and Drew Brees
are not one and two in football we know
that at this point okay I know I was a
little wrong about Tom Brady should have
had him probably at five or six okay
instead of nine or ten I get that and
I'm just going to Kurt Warner I'm saying
it right now you're wrong man he put
Brees and Brady one and two and he
trolled me and I didn't like that wasn't
cool so I'm just letting him know he was
wrong he was wrong the st. surviving one
I don't know you don't know what to say
don't worry I'll take him from here
trying to decide to I just let you keep
digging
yes just like I've been in say hey those
guys are really good but to say that
they are better than to Sean Watson or
mahomes or Rodgers or Russell Wilson at
this point since Ain my ratings were
closer at WEEI hey call him up get him
on explain himself okay yeah I'm digging
myself I don't care
I'm just envisioning I don't know should
it be boxing or should it be it's not
that crucial you and Kurt Yeah right
it's not that Cruz for charity I have a
lot of respect for Kurt but he should
all be there for the American Foundation
that bothered me he said I did it for
clique I'm just trying to think what I
bet on you or what I bet on Kurt you
would better you better bet on me I
don't know
Kurt stuff though I don't know I I think
I'm on Team Kurt for that one oh good
you might not be in the next segment of
this show
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports